the Joe Rogan experience dude what do
you think about Adesanya and Yoel Romero
is that real it's not confirmed yet is
it no I sent you something he sent that
to me and I was like holy [ __ ] I cuz I
was at I fell asleep I woke up more like
here we go
but is it not confirmed someone troll me
no I found one of the websites I follow
on Instagram but usually though they
leak there and then it gets announced
but if he does fight yo Romero and when
I was talking to Jorge and you're
Emile's manager when I was doing the
food truck with Jorge he was just like
Oh
Jorge's getting the fight man I was like
no he's coming out philosophy OHS think
about his [ __ ] losses because he has
us do you think he lost Apollo coast I
was like like no one got robbed but I
can see why they get Paul but you have
no unit there he was think about before
that the Robert Whittaker fight yeah
[ __ ] with that too he definitely got
robbed in the second Whittaker fine I
Christ I thought he won that fight yeah
I just had that many many times too and
I haven't really heard a good argument
against it he had him hurt real bad
yeah at least two rounds yeah I'd have
to go back I remember at the time I did
score it for Whittaker here's my thing
that's fine
II think he won yeah all right I can see
that I see both sides but that's an
argument forgiven you'll Romero the
title shot because it's not like you got
if you got start standing game title
shot you like what are you doing is it
real this is on you off page [ __ ]
March 7th here's the problem Noel hasn't
heard if you-all hasn't heard anything
but that's on y'all's page I know but he
goes a lot of people putting saying we
fight March people putting saying we
fight more how about should I be ready
should be ready gay Jesus
how about Andrew Schultz okay Andrew
Schultz is super close with Izzy and he
saw that and he goes dude why would is
he fight this guy doesn't speak very
good English I'm like what I'm like dude
hold on what yes yes he don't speak
English she needs a guy to speak good
English right because you don't
understand your Romero is such a [ __ ]
nightmare and for Izzy to go after you
well it just ups the legend of Izzy this
is what he's doing is perfect
trust me it's perfect Andrew
stay in your lane [ __ ] this up I talked
if he talked is he out of it
I'd be so mad at him he would but
imagine if he did what if Andrew had
some [ __ ] magic hypnosis power he was
like dr. Schultz I am I'm not gonna talk
English like what the [ __ ] are we doing
why'd you do that
don't forget Jesus don't forget
dude how about one that fight is
confirmed Ferguson khabib is how the
[ __ ] did people not understand he was
saying don't forget you know out of all
the times that I've ever not done
post-fight commentary that was the time
I was the most mad would they not let
you I wasn't there I wasn't there for
that hos him so when he was say it was a
fight that I wasn't there but it was if
somewhere where was that oh no we went
and don't forget Jesus look I I know a
lot of Cuban people I know what the [ __ ]
he's saying he's saying don't forget
Jesus it's not dope go for gay don't
forget why would he say what what I get
up so we can hear it was a fight night
that's why you didn't do it yeah John
he's got a Bible quote on his forehead
[Applause]
not forget Jesus ah dude the thing is
he's going what's wrong with you
Americans what's wrong with the
Americans you forget you forget you
forget Jesus you gay people no that's
exactly what he's for a second I'm gonna
be honest I'm gonna be honest I did a
little bit I was like we know because he
lines it up with what's wrong with you
America what's wrong with you here's the
problem here's the problem he said
forget pretty clear that's what [ __ ] you
forget you forget right but if we did
Jesus leaving JG
Iza is that really what he said yeah
play that [ __ ] again bro okay you forget
the USA you forget you forgot the best
in the world
[Applause]
not for gage eases people maybe but
maybe not forget Jesus it's like what
happened do you not forget Jesus there
wasn't like there was some gay thing
that was going on and he was commenting
on and I know but he's so bad at English
he's so bad it easily could be don't
forget Jesus he said go for Jesus
don't forget Jesus the only promise he
goes what's wrong with you USA what's
wrong with you you forget the number one
Jesus what's wrong with you go back go
back
don't don't forget don't forget don't
forget Jesus but he says don't forget
right one more time
cuz it does down first of all pause for
a second you gotta remember he just got
hit in the head gang times right I mean
what fight was this do we remember and
look he's got John 3:16 or 318 I don't
know an app but bandana around his head
he's got a Bible quote on his [ __ ] go
for Jesus not for gay Jesus people go
for Jesus not forget Jesus yeah not you
forget you forget Jesus it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense period yeah
we're trying to say not for gage eases
that I make sense no no no there's no
rumors saying don't forget started a
rumor about Jesus being gay magic we
were the first ones after all these
years and then it becomes like
everybody's talking about it like you
always tell there was a scroll shut
broke it down shut chopped down Jesus
was doing of course he loves everybody
it's confusing though I can see how
people mix those when we first watch on
it always gonna harm the pain on
USA and gays but I remember thinking
don't really turn it that he was saying
don't forget because a lot of Cubans
with that I'd say they might say don't
forget yeah don't forget don't forget we
go out yeah don't forget o'clock we be
here they have that sort of way of
talking so when I hear don't forget
always say that make sense get Jesus I'm
gonna assume he said don't forget Jesus
doesn't make sense we'd say now know for
gage kept saying USA you forget USA you
forget and then for gay for gay but he's
barely speaking English that's barely
that's not there's no way you should
hold him accountable to be able to
accentuate every word correct I think I
think most people got over it yeah and
we just realized we just rehab listen
man that guy is one of the most scary
athletes I've ever seen in the UFC when
he knocked how Chris widen with that
flying need it just comes out of nowhere
I mean he does [ __ ] to people man he
throws people he took our [ __ ]
straight head kick from Derek Brunson
right to the neck just walked it off
like it was nothing
pretending like nothing happened does it
really use his wrestling either well it
doesn't really [ __ ] yeah he just wants
to knock your head up I think with his
mass right the amount of muscle that he
has so much month and the explosive
energy required to try to take somebody
down I don't know if he can do that for
five minutes for five rounds no
especially the guy would take down
defense yeah no and then he's a little
bit more vulnerable with his striking if
he can't explode see he's not a
technical striker in the vein of style
bender style benders a technical striker
Kyle bender is setting you up he's
giving you look sand traps doing things
to you to see how you respond and then
he'll fake things and high kick you
he'll do some [ __ ] to you that you don't
know it's coming your wells not that
your well is exploding at a way that you
can't handle you can't be on guard all
the time you can't be like this because
you're gonna burn out so there's gonna
be a moment where you relax there's
gonna be a moment where you you can't
quite move out of the way quick enough
and that's what he's gonna leave on you
Casey with that flying nail you hit why
but you like it yes I I think for style
bender though and just look it up the
matchup and
Stabbin did a robert whittaker III do
think is he finishes them I do it's all
about it physique and just keep him from
taking them down cuz if he if he's there
standing up
the thing about Yoel is these leaps
these power just just giant explosive
movements but is he's gonna be aware of
that he's gonna try to assume that I saw
it look at Robert Whittaker never really
had an opportunity to explode like that
is he so good at distance and he's
fought big powerful guys before so he's
seen that
[Applause]